[Music]
24:00 coming back on Fox little do they
know are you are you gonna be in the
show is like I you said do we know do we
know do we know um I love that I I do
not know yet I'm have high hopes the
fans on Twitter I'm hoping to hear soon
people have been over the moon about
this and really supportive and really
totally Twitter your fans on Twitter are
saying you've got to be you've got their
very very vocal about this like I'm not
gonna watch if you're not on and no
Chloe no watch E and no Chloe no watch E
would be like peanut butter I feel the
same way
so everyone say you know I will not
watch Miran I will riot if you're not
president and then I'll get the one
person the one person that's like you
know enough about Chloe I like her but I
can watch the show without her
oh that's laughs yeah there's always
that one person that I just tweet like
no you can't I'll kill you you know your
fans are so rabid they actually put up
that they made one of them made a
picture of you have Chloe in the
Situation Room
during the bin Laden raid where he was
killed they put you in that familiar
here I love how artfully that was done
the art but you know people you're
always at a computer on the 24 they
always had you at a computer always it's
just all the time yeah I'm just like you
know dismantling a nuclear bomb or just
all the craps going down but you know
what I was doing on that computer the
whole time really what just typing
affirmations to myself yeah so it'd all
be going down and I'm like you look
really pretty today Mary - doing a
really good job acting keep up the good
work
don't take key vers intensity so
personally he's just acting he really
does like you characters would come over
like hoping to see the hacked in
governmental files and they would just
see your divine child of God angels and
unicorns God don't make no junk that's
very nice I'm gonna watch the show
differently now that I know you're doing
that the new movie the the kings of
summer dark very funny
all in one yes it ends some hilarious
people including yourself are in this in
this movie great cast Nick Hoffman Megan
Mullally yes two kids that run away from
home and to build a house in the woods
well we have a clip here I think we
don't know I play a police chief you
play a police chief it was tough I could
not handle the baton think of it didn't
have me apprehend anybody really yeah
that's harder than it looks huh yeah I'm
not very tough you know I cry it like
the iPad commercial
we all do that let's take a look at this
clip from the kings of summer
the problem with Joseph's habit is that
one day there will be an actual
emergency or a violent crime coming from
this house yeah well the night is still
young
mr. toy are you familiar with the boy
who cried wolf yes I experienced a
childhood on the planet Earth so yes
I've heard of that one do you think you
can apply it to my situation in an
allegorical fashion ok it's a story that
involves a boy constantly cries wolf and
when the wolf finally comes he doesn't
like the boy who cried what whoa you the
boy who cried one Oh get off my porch
for a hundred dick in the dirt
[Applause]